cosmetics groceries a new phone
a year's worth of laundry detergent
citizens of the chinese city of suzhou
entered an official lottery to win up to
200 yen or roughly 30
from the government in order to spend it
in any way they liked
but the money that the people won was
not physical cash
it was digital yuan part of the chinese
government's ambitious plan to create
one of the world's first state-backed
digital currencies
here's how the system works and the
goals that china wants to pursue with it
in the last few weeks of 2020 the
people's bank of china rolled out a
pilot program
in the eastern chinese city of suzhou
they had to download
an app and have it on the phone we spoke
to one
woman who used her 200 yuan to buy
a year's worth of laundry detergent for
her family and she did that online
at an online store but she said it went
very smoothly and it went just like
regular digital payments do in china
there are two advantages at least so far
that
that the people's bank of china and
other chinese officials have touted for
this new digital currency one is that
you don't need an internet connection
to make these purchases there are places
in china
where you can't get good internet
signals
the other advantage is for merchants um
having the people's bank of china itself
managing this currency would cut out the
middleman in a certain
uh respect china's actually already
pretty advanced in this regard in that
many people
hardly use cash at all in their daily
lives they mostly pay for things
through alipay which is owned by ant
group
or under wechat pay which is owned by 10
cent
so most people um like in beijing i
almost always pay
with my phone right now with a qr code
on my phone that comes up in wechat or
an alipay that
is then scanned our understanding is
that what the people's bank of china
wants to do is quite
similar except that it wouldn't happen
necessarily through through alipay or
through wechat pay it would happen
through a separate app that the pboc has
created that would allow people to pay
that way
10 cents an ant declined to comment
chinese authorities have given their own
stated reasons for why they
see benefits in this digital currency to
have a better sense of how people are
spending their money
in a macro way you have a sense of how
money flows through the economy on a
micro scale
and this is something that many in the
west would probably not be comfortable
with and many in china frankly would not
be comfortable with is that
it would allow authorities to be able to
track precisely how you
or my neighbor or the person down the
street is spending the money are they
spending their money on
buying things they shouldn't be buying
whatever however you define that are
they are they gambling with their money
are they doing this or that with their
money
there are many countries in the world
and many of them are
looking into and exploring the idea of
digital currencies but there haven't
been
major economies like china's that have
gotten to the stage of rolling out
pilot programs where citizens are
spending this digital currency
you know right now it's rather modest
than what it's trying to do
it you know i mean they they say it's
just to replace
physical cash but of course this could
just be the first step